Don't be fooled by your BMW coolant gauge. It's lying to you. Let me tell you a story about how I know
They told me you couldn't pull INPA or ISTA level data from a golden air of BMW's using just an ice on it
They said you needed an ancient Windows laptop and outdated dealer software or spent $200 or more at a specialty shop
Just for a diagnosis. That wasn't good enough for me for patents later
I built my own hardware to prove them wrong and thankfully phase two doesn't require soldering
Here's what that looks like in actual practice
The first 20 minutes of driving my coolant tense with spite to 101 before cooling down and then dropped to 84 on the freeway
The app noticed by E39 there's running 60 degrees hotter than normal while the dash gauge was out to lunch
Hans the built in AI engineer
Instantly flag the sticky thermostat before it could be stranded
So I grabbed the parts and I completed the job myself
Then I ran a sonic pulse acoustic analysis task
The app listened to the engine clear the rod bearings and Tissa one-loading spite fanos rattle and a lifter
Confirming the block it's helped to maintain performance these machines the man preservation
The analog built by and for enthusiasts built for the analog era